hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from the final round
of the super bit chess classic alireza
furuja versus maxim bashar lagrov and
both of them are really in a position
where they could use a win in the
tournament maksim is doing somewhat
better
and if uh for example levon and the
wesley are leading the tournament but if
they draw uh draw their games in the
final round and maxine wins his game
with the black pieces against caliresa
he has a chance to catch up to them
and uh play uh play in the tiebreaks for
first place which of course means more
money if he wins but also you can just
win the tournament uh and for alireza as
he is our only 2800 player in the event
uh he has not been doing um a very very
2800
in the tournament and he would very much
like to finish the tournament on um on a
high note uh so he has the white piece
it's the final round uh it's up to him
to to win so let's see what happened as
it is quite quite interesting alireza
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 c for g6 knight
to f3 and bishop to g7 maxine uh decides
to go for the king's indian defense this
time we have g3
c6 and not bishop to g2 we have d5 both
players castle castles castles and not
knights to e5 so this is the classical
stuff nothing uh nothing new here uh the
capturs and c for knight captures and
bishop to e6 now so it's a looks like a
weird square for the bishop because
you're blocking your e7 pawn but you are
uh your real plan is to put the bishop
on d5 and trade it for white's a very
strong uh light square bishop as your
bishop and c8 really wasn't doing all
that much so b3 defending the knight
here
uh bishop to d5 and now bishop to b2
alireza pinkett was both of his bishops
with knight b to d7 and now uh there are
a couple of games for knight b to d2 was
played but here we have knight to c3 and
it is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how uh
maxine goes about this he captures the
bishop on g2 you do not want to trade
knight for bishop so you want to
eliminate white's strong bishop here uh
bishop captures on g2 king captures and
b5 now expanding on the queen side
chasing away the knight from such an
active square knight to d2 and now pawn
to e5 and black can be very happy here
yeah he executes e5 and uh
opens up the position the captures
knight captures and not knight d to e4
now offering a trade of knights soon the
bishops will get traded off we're
offering a trade of queens so here we
can pretty much trade everything if um
the players choose to do so so instead
we have knight eat the g4 first saying
that okay if you capture i can always
capture back with the knight and now
that's exactly what happens we have a
ninth captures on f6 with check knight
captures and now queen to c2 avoiding
the queen trade queen to e7 uh black uh
gets the queen away from the d file as
you know white is putting a rook on the
on the d file uh rook f the e1 and the
now comes queen to c5 now interestingly
here uh rook f2d8 or rook 8 to c8 seems
like an automatic
defending the c pawn you want to push it
and also just putting the rook on an
open d file but maxine goes for queen to
c5 first it's a sort of a an improvement
on the position the queen is a bit more
active on c5 then on e7 plus you have
this immediate thread of b4 it would win
the knight the knight cannot move the
queen is undefended so okay alireza has
to play rook eight to c1 first and now
rook f the e8
uh and now we have knight to d1 just
offering a trade of queens uh and here
maxine goes for it we have queen cactus
rook captures and rook the e6 now
defending the pawn here knights the e3
uh and now comes rook to d8 and now how
do you uh pl how do you play this with
white uh
rook e to c1 seems like the way to go
you want to put pressure on that c pawn
the problem is black has knight to d5
and now what do you play knight captures
rook characters and you can for example
play bishop captures king captures but
now if you capture on c5 on c6 uh we're
gonna capture on e2 so yeah you can't
really play this and if we push this
then we just move the rook defend the
pawn and everything is perfectly fine so
instead we have knights to f1 by alireza
at knights to d5 now and bishop captures
on g7 we have king captures and a3
taking away the b4 square from maxim's
knight we have a5 and now knight to d2
we have b4 and algresa closes the
position with a4 and we reached the
position from the thumbnail maxine plays
rook to e3 and this is where the
fun really starts now how can already
continue here of course you cannot
capture the rook if you capture you mess
up your own pawn structure black wins
back the rook and that's just it black
will continue by winning this game
alersa goes for rook captures on c6
right away but rook to b2 just adding a
defender to the b3 pawn and preparing to
activate your knight is also something
to consider for example rook c3 knight
d4 attacks the rook and now c5 this is
probably what maxine had in mind he
wanted to give up the exchange to
create a pass pawn here and let's say
knight captures on c3 knight captures on
c3 and next we're going to push c4 and
create a pass b pawn let's say king f1
we're going to push c4 and after b
captures rook d4 we're going to win the
pawn back and we have a defended uh b a
pass b pawn uh on the fourth uh
rank which is incredibly strong so this
is what maxim wanted and pretty much
whenever you have maxim playing the
groomfield or the
kings indian or some something like this
or even the sicilian
night or he will always give up the the
rook for the knight and uh
push very hard for the win but here
alireza went to rook captures on c6 he
thinks this is um
less risky uh and okay we have rook to
c3 now threatening the rook uh if all
there is a trades then maxim gets uh
past pawn on c3 so knight to c4 and here
rook captures and b3 uh we have uh okay
if you go for the a5 pawn this is
possible then we play rook to a3 and
after let's say e4 attacking the knight
tonight's the c3 and now e5 we're gonna
capture on a4 and this is the position
that we would have uh white would have
this very strong pawn on e5 but it's not
a pass pawn and black does have a past b
pawn so
that there's that if you capture on a5
so first alireza kicks away the knight
we have rooked the e8 now not allowing
the capture as the rookhani one would
hang
knight the d6 attacking the rook and now
rook to e6 we rook to d1 now threatening
to pick up the knight and knight to f6
and this is the critical moment that
basically decides the game uh what can
alireza play here now i'm just going to
show you what he played and then i'm
going to tell you what he should have
played he played e5 right away now
uh to understand why he played e5
because if you just look at this move e5
what is that
first we have to ask ourselves what
happens if rook to c7 so how does black
defend the the f7 pawn well of course
aleris has spotted that if he plays this
he loses the game because of the tactic
rook captures knight rook captures and
not knight forking the two rooks and
once the rook moves let's say rook d to
c6 we're going to capture on c7 rook
capture is now rook a3 we're going to
win the a4 pawn and of course black wins
this end game easily as he will have two
connected pass pawns on the queen side
so that's why alireza played e5 as
uh he wanted the the rook to move from
e6 the thing is you first play rook to
d4 that's what alireza should have
played
and it seems um seems odd but now you're
preparing e5 and you're you're taking
away the g4 square from the uh from the
black knight so that's that's the good
stuff but here after e5 uh there's the
problem maxine plays knight to g4 and
now it seems like oh okay of course the
pawn cannot be captured now rook to c7
is great for white because your rook can
no longer capture the knight here that's
the idea but after knight the g4 here
now what can you play here okay rook the
c7 this is what alireza
now comes knight captures an e5
defending on f7 and f4 and the problem
here is that maxine plays rook to d3 now
you don't move the knight but you are
saying i'm gonna capture your rook on d1
and the thing is if you move the rook
let's say rook d to c1 we're just going
to play rook e captures on d6 and after
pawn captures here we're going to play
rook to d7 and black will have enough to
win this game let's say rook c5 attacks
the a5 pawn we're going to block this
defend the a5 pawn
where up upon we're going to win this
pawn as well and the black will win this
game so that's the idea so uh rook
captures on d3 is forced this is what
alareza plays knight captures and now
rook captures an f7 uh king to g8 now
the knight is hanging and also if the
knight moves the rook hangs so rook the
d7 the only move that keeps the game
going for alireza now b3 maxime starts
pushing his pass pawn and now you
already know that you will
have to give up this um uh knight for
the pawn the rook cannot move because
our knight will hang here so you have to
try something rook to d8 check king g7
rook d7 check king to f8 and now knight
to c4 so we moved the knight
but now comes pawn to b2 and this is a
bit of a bit of a rushed idea maybe by
maxine there's the even more tricky
knight to c5 attacking the rook taking
control over the b7 square so rook to b7
is not an option
and for the moment guarding the b3 pawn
but we're actually going after the a4
pawn and now let's say rook d8 czech
king will move rook to b8 going after
the pawn now we play rook to e2 with
check king h3 and now rook to c2 we
challenge the knight and after the
knight moves now we play rook to a2 so
uh the knight controls the b2 three pawn
that seems to be very important in this
line knight b1 now rook captures on a4
and we finish by having two connected
pass passports on the queen side with
a great winning chances for for uh
for maxine but okay he decided to push
the b pawn right away and now all there
is a place knight captures on b2 uh and
here me this was perhaps a little bit
rushed but um uh let's discuss rook to
b7 this is also possible but then uh
maxime has this forcing line rook to e2
check king f3 attacks the rook now rook
f to check king e3 and knight b4
are offering a rook for the promotion of
the queen and here knight captures and
b2 is forced a rook captures on b2 and
rook will capture on h7
and this is the position that we will
get
where
uh it's uh gonna be tough but it is uh
it is kind of possible to win the game
uh sorry about that uh having a bit of a
bit of a sore throat it would seem
uh but yeah after rook captures on h7
that would be that would be great for
for maxine it would still require
fighting but it would be definitely a
long way to go but uh okay after b2
knight capture some b2 was played right
away uh knight captures and now rook to
a7 this is how it is it wants to hold
this but not knight captures rook
captures uh there's no action on the
queen side anymore and now at least the
attention is focused towards the king
side so here knight to b6 uh g4 now
knight to d7 uh we have king to g3 and
now rook the e3 with check so can maxine
win this he has a knight alireza is up
upon uh it's not gonna be easy but uh
with perfect play it should it should be
winning
uh we have king to h4 knight to f6 now
rook to a8 with check so how can alareza
try and create a fortress here king f7
we're going to play rook to a7 check
rook the e7 of course the rook trade is
never possible for aliens if he trades
then the game is winning for for maxine
uh rook a5 now knight to e4 we have f5
alarism wants to trade on
as many pawns as possible because if we
take all the pawns from the board then
it will be a draw uh so here rook to d7
uh f captures on g6h captures and then
now rook to a4 attacks the knight we
have rook to a7 defending and the rook
to a5
uh king f6 we have g5 with check king
back to f7 and king to g4 we have
knights to d6 and now rook to a4 so he
doesn't want to allow any checks along
the fourth rank knights to f5 and now
pawn to h4 so how can uh maxine make
progress here if the rook keeps
controlling the fourth rank well the
idea is that we have to put the knight
to h5 and this is of course his next
maneuver knight g7 king of three we have
knight to h5 and rook to b4 so just
keeping control over the fourth rank
rook to d7 now comes king to g4 and rook
to d6 we have rook to e4 and now rook to
d1
rook to a4 and now king to e6 now we
bring the king into the game and we will
use our rook to shield our king so here
rook a6 check we have rooked the d6 of
course again the rook trade is
impossible for for alireza
rook to a4 we have king to e5 and now
rook to a3 if you keep the rook on the
fourth rank which of course you can
let's say rook before rook d4 check
forces the rook trade and then we easily
win so rook a3
uh and now rook to d4 with check we have
king to h3 now king f5 slowly but surely
our king is winning crucial squares here
we have rook to a5 with check king to e4
and now king to g4 so not allowing the
black king too much control but now king
e3 opening up a discovery king h3 now
rook to e4 uh so uh
we want to we want to bring the king
over to f2 it doesn't really matter what
white plays rook to a1 now king f2 we
have rook to a2 with check and king f3
rook a3 check we have rook to e3 again
we cannot trade rooks uh as the end game
would be winning rook to a4 and now
knight to f4 with check and he was in
this position on move 74 that uh alireza
furuja resigned the game and a brilliant
brilliant victory for maxima sherlock
who uh
uh not only wins his uh uh uh final
final round game uh but also catches up
to the leaders wesley so and levon aaron
and they will now play a a tiebreak uh
mini event to see who will
be the true win uh winner of this of
this wonderful event so here you resign
you are in check you have to move once
you move we're going to deliver a check
here k1 knight to h5 and now we will
either pick up all of these pawns or if
white uh insists on defending those
pawns then we were we're just gonna
check made the white king and now it
doesn't matter what you play rook a3
check king to g4 rook a fortune king to
h3 and next move rook to g2 will be
checkmate regardless of what you played
there is no stopping this okay you could
play something like rook a2 but that's
weird uh it would be it would be fine
for example if you did not have the h5
move then it would be a stalemate but
you have h5 and then it's still going to
be checkmate so really wonderful stuff
by maxine uh
it all came down to this e5 push by
alireza rook the d for preparing e5 was
the way to go uh but um okay it's easy
to to make a mistake you are in time
trouble you still need to reach move 40
but what really got the game going was
maxime's creativity with this rook the
e3 idea just remaneuvering the rook
using a nice tactic and just the
possibility of re-maneuvering the rook
over to c3 allowed for him to even get
some winning chances with with the black
pieces here so brilliant stuff by maxine
uh tough break for alireza but he will
have to he will have to try harder if he
wants to remain in the in the 2800 club
that's uh that's only for
um well
incredibly incredibly precise and
persistent players as you can see magnus
has already been in the in the 2800 club
for for over a decade and that's uh i
mean that's pretty incredible uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys uh
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh
tara caldwell rip market lucious lelouch
and david kimura for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this event as
we still have the tie breaks uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and and sorry
about me having a bit of a sore throat
probably it will pass
see you soon